during a recent interview with Sebastian
Gorka Donald Trump continued to promise
what he has been quite frequently
recently which is they're going to
indict me well I'm going to indict them
then
um and I'll show you this moment and
then we'll discuss really dangerous
rhetoric
the numbers are through the roof we're
beating everybody by a lot and we're
beating Biden by a lot and one of the
reasons it was interesting somebody
wrote a very strong piece the other day
I could tell you who but let's not even
use this name because perhaps you
wouldn't want it but wrote a very strong
piece that they're afraid to have me
back in that's why they're doing the
indictment stuff because they don't want
to be indicted now I would do it only
very fairly of course of course but they
don't want to be indicted so they say we
can't let this guy win but there was
tremendous corruption on the other side
don't forget they spied on my campaign
and we caught them
they did things that nobody would have
believed then they had two fake
impeachments that we won and so much
else the Mueller report which showed new
collusion at the end of two years showed
no collusion and number
okay so uh we also heard a similar
sentiment during his recent Bedminster
speech in addition to closing the border
and removing all of the criminal
elements that have illegally invaded our
country
make it America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours
[Music]
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
of the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
so what's fascinating is we've heard
from
uh
Republicans for a while now we've talked
about this a lot this week and even just
on the show that there's this two-tier
justice system designed to go after
conservatives and benefit Democrats and
that's what Trump is a victim of and the
evidence they bring forward is not
evidence they don't break forward
evidence I guess it's just the
accusation very empty and that is going
to then be the justification to actually
weaponize the government against people
based on their political affiliation and
if Trump were to become president he
actually is committing to weaponizing
his office to go after his political
opponents to go after the Biden crime
family it's not let the system play out
if there's crimes investigate them if
there's something
um that is a clear violence violation of
a law and has evidence for that that can
be proven in accord all that let the
process play itself out as president I
want to be
um separated from that no it's going to
be I'm gonna figure out a way to get
Biden locked up and it's a similar thing
we're seeing with this weaponization
subcommittee within the House of
Representatives where it's by its name
supposed to be looking into the
weaponization of the federal government
um but in reality it's those individuals
in their positions in the federal
government weaponizing that position in
the federal government to help Trump
politically and to
um perpetuate these conspiracy theories
about the FBI doing this thing and that
thing and Twitter and uh Jim Jordan
trying to get involved in the Manhattan
D.A investigation in
the name of investigating the
weaponization of the federal government
they're weaponizing the federal
government and
um it's pretty terrifying thinking about
the prospect of trump using his position
if God forbid he were able to get back
into that position in that way one other
narrative that kind of was intertwined
in that little clip you saw was one he
also recently posted about on true
social here's a screenshot it says
Congress will hopefully now look at the
ever continuing witch hunts in election
interference against me on perfectly
legal boxes of course that doesn't seem
to be accurate and what I've been
warning of and talking about a good bit
on my show you can find that at Luke
Beasley on YouTube definitely go check
out my show if you uh are liking what
you're watching now
is that Trump is preparing similar to
how he did before 2020 to claim on
election interference there was fraud
but this time while he'll probably
include dead voters and we talked about
earlier in today's show Ruby Friedman or
Freeman and claims like that the
suitcases and ballot stuffing and big
massive dump some ballot dumps all over
the place he will probably make those
claims as well and on top of it he'll
say it was rigged if he loses to Joe
Biden because of election interference
when in reality what we're seeing is
just Trump being held accountable for
his violations
of the law it has been great being with
you today
um one more reminder to check me out at
Luke Beasley on YouTube make sure you
are also subscribed to this YouTube
channel the David Pac-Man show and I
will see you if you remember on the
bonus show